PETER BLUM: Hi, everyone,
and welcome to our session,
Innovations in DDoS,
WAF, Firewalls,
and Network-based
Threat Detection.
My name is Peter Blum.
And I run the network security
PM team here at Google Cloud.
And I'm joined by Emil, who I'm
going to let introduce himself.
EMIL KINER: Thanks, Peter.
Hi.
My name is Emil Kiner.
And I run product management
for our DDoS mitigation and web
application firewall product
line called Cloud Armor.
PETER BLUM: So today,
I'm going to start off
by sharing our vision
for network security
and provide a brief
overview of our solutions.
After that, I'm
going to hand over
to Emil, who's
going to get us up
to date on all the
latest with Cloud Armor.
And then I'll pick back up and
cover all the great new things
that we've been doing
in network protection
with our Cloud firewall,
NAT, and IDS offerings.
So let me start with our broader
vision of network security
at Google Cloud.
As you can see in
our vision statement,
our goal with network security
is to make it invisible.
We want to weave it
into the cloud fabric
with automated, but verifiable,
protection, simplified control,
and clear prioritization
of critical threats
with relevant context.
And where we can, we also
want to provide the solution.
Emil is actually going
to talk about some
of the new capabilities in
Cloud Armor in just a bit
that I think are a
perfect example of what
we're working towards
across the entire portfolio.
I wanted to provide an overview
of our network security
portfolio.
I'm going to overlay this on
a high-level diagram that's
showing flows in, between,
and out of our cloud.
First, in terms of
handling incoming traffic
to internet-facing services,
we provide an integrated edge
delivery stack that includes
a global load balancer and CDN
that provide for availability,
scalability, and performance.
And then built into
this stack to provide
our global-scale DDoS protection
and a great web application
firewall is Cloud
Armor, which Emil
is going to dig into shortly.
And then we provide
defense in depth
with a network firewall and NAT
service built into our cloud
networking fabric.
These same two
services also provide
for protection and privacy
for traffic out of the network
as well.
And as you can expect, our
network security solutions
are integrated in our
Cloud Security products,
bringing in context about
threats, integration
with our bot, fraud, and
application access solutions
as well.
And then we provide
a full complement
of network-level
telemetry from metadata
about traffic flows inside
and out of the cloud, data
about traffic we block at the
network and application layer,
plus we provide full
packet inspection
services with our packet
mirroring capability.
And with the next
few months, you'll
see we've also released
network threat detection.
It's a system called
Cloud IDS that
was a joint partnership with
Palo Alto Networks, where
we use their threat detection
systems within our own cloud.
All the alerts and telemetry
from these products
are also integrated into
our own threat-hunting,
alert management, and unified
security management services.
And then we also integrate with
third-party SIEM and source
systems as well.
So with that, let
me hand over to Emil
to take us through Cloud Armor.
EMIL KINER: Thanks, Peter.
Today, I'm excited
to share with you
all the great new
developments and capabilities
we've released with Cloud
Armor over the past year.
Cloud Armor is Google Cloud's
DDoS protection service
and web application firewall.
It provides global-scale defense
against volumetric, protocol,
and application-level attacks.
And it's built using the same
technology and infrastructure
that we originally
built to protect
our own billion-user properties,
such as Search, Gmail,
and Maps.
Cloud Armor reflects
our vision of bringing
to bear Google's global scale
to protect customer workloads
wherever they are deployed.
Cloud Armor, in
addition to the rest
of our edge infrastructure,
including load balancing
and CDN, can be deployed
in front of your websites
or services, whether
you are running
on Google Cloud, on-prem, or
with another infrastructure
provider.
Over the past year, we've
been privileged enough
to help protect a growing
set of enterprise customers
while moving quickly to
expand our capabilities
and scope of protection,
all while investing
heavily into building a
cutting-edge machine learning
solution to meet the evolving
threat landscape head-on.
I'm excited to
share with you some
of our recent developments.
Earlier this year, we introduced
Cloud Armor Managed Protection
Plus, a managed application
protection service
which bundles together all
the features and capabilities
of Cloud Armor with additional
value-added services
into an enterprise-friendly
and predictable
monthly subscription.
Managed Protection Plus
delivers unrivaled application
protection while providing
the peace of mind
that Google has your back 24/7.
In addition to including
all Cloud Armor WAF
rules, policies, and requests,
Managed Protection Plus
includes premium capabilities,
like Adaptive Protection,
as well as 24/7 DDoS response
support, which gives you
access to Google's DoS experts
to help mitigate attacks
targeting your services.
Further, with DDoS
Bill Protection,
we're removing the
financial risk of DDoS
by insulating you from spikes in
your networking expenses caused
by successful DDoS attacks.
Over the next several
quarters, you'll
see us continue to add
additional premium capabilities
and manage services into Managed
Protection Plus subscription.
Next, we want to talk about
our new Adaptive Protection
capability, which
has already generated
a lot of positive feedback
from a fast-growing enterprise
customer base.
Adaptive Protection is a
machine learning-based solution
to detect and
efficiently respond
to application-level distributed
denial of service attacks.
We have developed
Adaptive Protection
over the last several years
in close collaboration
with external and
internal customers,
like Project Shield,
continuously training
on attack data we observe
against all of Google.
Adaptive Protection develops
a per-application baseline
by learning what normal
traffic patterns look
like for each
protected application.
In addition to
traffic volumes, we
assess dozens of
features and attributes
of the incoming request traffic
to establish the baseline.
Next, Adaptive Protection
monitors traffic flows
in real time and
generates alerts
for anomalous or
potentially attack traffic.
A second set of
machine learning model
then distills the
anomalous traffic
into a dynamically
generated signature.
The result of this analysis
is presented immediately
as part of the original alert.
We also take it a step further
and provide a proposed Cloud
Armor rule that can
mitigate the attack
traffic with minimal
to no collateral damage
to the good baseline traffic.
Adaptive Protection provides
near-real-time attack detection
with immediately
actionable alerts,
saving your incident responders
critical minutes or hours
of time-consuming log
analysis, triage, and other IR
activities, allowing you to
safely and efficiently deliver
reliable services.
This is the main Adaptive
Protection dashboard.
Here, you can see
incoming traffic patterns
for all of your
services protected
by Adaptive
Protection as well as
the list of attack alerts
detected over the selected time
horizon.
When we click on
one of the alerts,
we see a much more
detailed view of the attack
and the results of our machine
learning-powered analysis.
We present the
machine-determined confidence
level in our findings, the
size and shape of the attack,
as well as the attack signature.
For this attack
in particular, we
have identified and
presented a unique signature
across the source region code,
remote host, and target host
attributes.
We also propose a rule that can
be deployed in near real time
to mitigate the attack
as it's occurring.
Because of the sensitivity
of our detection models,
alerts are frequently generated
while an attack is still
ramping up, allowing you to
respond before it has a chance
to impact your services.
When the operator
clicks Apply, they
can see the proposed rule, as
well as additional guidance
from Adaptive Protection, to aid
in understanding and assessing
the expected impact of
the proposed mitigation.
Mitigations can also be deployed
in a logging-only or preview
mode to validate
effectiveness and safety.
Specifically, you can
see the expected impact
of the proposed rule on
the good and bad traffic.
In this case, the
proposed rule is
expected to impact 0%
of the good traffic
from the baseline while
blocking about all or nearly all
of the incoming attack.
So we are providing
an end-to-end solution
to detect and mitigate attacks
with near-real-time actionable
alerts containing dynamically
generated mitigations, which
are narrowly targeted for
just the malicious traffic.
This insight not only
saves incident responders
critical time in reacting and
mounting an effective defense,
but also provides
the information
to aid triage efforts and
help explain why we consider
the traffic suspicious.
Next, we're proud to announce
the preview release of Cloud
Armor Bot Management
with a deep integration
with reCAPTCHA Enterprise, which
is Google Cloud's enterprise
version of the leading bot
and fraud protection product.
While customers can use these
products together already,
we wanted to simplify
the deployment process
and provide a more integrated
and scalable experience.
ReCAPTCHA Enterprise provides
a world-class bot detection
mechanism developed
from and continuously
learning from a
globally distributed
multi-million
website install base.
With this deep integration,
Cloud Armor customers
can now leverage reCAPTCHA
to detect and block
bot traffic within their
Cloud Armor security policies.
All of this occurs at the
edge of Google's network,
far upstream of your
protected workloads,
allowing us to leverage the
global scale of our network
to mitigate bot threats without
impacting the performance
of your applications.
Critically, with the
integrated solution,
Cloud Armor and
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
can protect customer
applications
without requiring server-side
changes on the application
to decipher and enforce
bot assessments.
You can configure Cloud
Armor security policies
in several ways to
leverage this integration.
You can configure
any rule action
to serve the
reCAPTCHA challenge,
forcing suspicious end
users to solve the puzzle
before being allowed through.
Additionally, you can instrument
your client-side applications
with the reCAPTCHA library
for seamless and silent bot
assessments and then have Cloud
Armor decipher and enforce
the assessment at the edge.
In addition to the
reCAPTCHA integration,
Cloud Armor Bot Management
introduces an enhanced set
of capabilities designed to
help you deploy an effective bot
management strategy.
These capabilities include
additional rule actions
to redirect traffic,
as well as the ability
to insert a custom header
into a suspicious request,
but otherwise allow it to
reach your application.
Customers use this custom
header to tag suspicious traffic
for alternative processing
within their workloads,
like sending to
a honeypot or not
completing a potentially
fraudulent transaction
without notifying the
bot that it was detected.
We're also proud to share
that one of our most highly
anticipated features,
rate limiting,
is now available in preview.
With Cloud Armor
per-client rate limiting,
users can ensure that
no client exceeds
a pre-configured threshold
through two new actions
for any existing or
new Cloud Armor rule.
With the throttle
action, requests
from individual clients will be
dropped when the client begins
exceeding the prescribed rate
to ensure that, on average,
the client's
request volume stays
within the configured threshold.
Similarly, the
rate-based ban action
aims to punish abuse of clients
by temporarily banning them
for a configured amount of time
if they exceed your threshold.
And clients can be
identified by their source
IP, X-Forwarded-For header,
or any arbitrary header,
like a session
identifier or a user ID.
Cloud Armor rate limiting
is an effective means
to detect and thwart
high-volume DDoS attempts,
mitigate credential
stuffing attacks,
all while ensuring the
availability and reliability
of your workloads.
Finally, Cloud Armor
edge security policies
are available in preview to
provide Cloud Armor protection
in front of Cloud CDN cache or
Google Cloud Storage buckets.
The new edge
security policy types
can be applied to protected
services in parallel
with the existing back-end
security policies.
The new policy types
are stored, evaluated,
and enforced even further
upstream in our edge
infrastructure before a request
can be served from the CDN's
cache or from a GCS bucket.
Requests that make it through
the edge security policy that
cannot be served from cache
are still evaluated by any
configured back-end security
policy for full Layer 7
filtering and WAF before it is
proxied back to your protected
application or origins.
Edge security policies
support IP and geo-filtering
to filter out unwelcome end
users or geographies in order
to comply with security
compliance, export controls,
or licensing agreements.
While delivering these much
anticipated capabilities,
we are continuing
to invest heavily
into expanding Cloud Armor
scope and depth of protection
to help protect your
applications and services.
So stay tuned.
Now I'll hand it back
to Peter to tell you
about more great developments
across our network security
products.
PETER BLUM: Thanks, Emil.
It's great to hear about
all the good stuff that's
happening with Cloud Armor.
Next, I'd like to get into
what's new and innovative
with network protection.
I'm going to cover innovations
in Cloud Firewall, Cloud
NAT, and Cloud IDS.
So let's start with
Cloud Firewall.
This is our integrated
virtual firewall service
for ingress, egress, and inside
the cloud network protection.
It's fully integrated
with Google's SDN fabric.
And the firewall
policy enforcement
is distributed
across that fabric.
And to make firewall
policies dynamic,
we allow for easier
microsegmentation
and provide a shift to a
zero-trust workload protection
posture by using network
tags and service accounts.
This removes the need for
encoding static IP addresses
into firewall rules and
makes protection dynamic.
The example I like to give is
you can add new microservices
with a tag.
And they'll automatically get
the established protection
rules.
And in terms of
recent innovations,
we have two great additions.
First is Firewall
Insights, which
provides information that helps
operators learn about which
firewall rules are used,
never used, and overshadowed
by other, more broad, rules.
This helps identify
misconfigurations,
attacks, and allows tightening
controls for better security.
And then we just released a
new capability in preview here
that highlights rules
that have perhaps
over-granted permissions,
which is a great opportunity
to tighten up your
firewall rules.
Next, we released
hierarchical firewall policies
earlier this year, which
allows creating and enforcing
a consistent set of
firewall policies
across an entire organization.
This improves protection
and simplifies
complex, large deployments.
The great thing is that once
you set up your organization's
standard set of
firewall policies,
any new projects added
automatically get that policy.
But it still allows
for local overrides
deeper within the
organization when required.
We find it's really
helping customers simplify
their firewall
configurations by reducing
the number of firewall rules
needed across an organization.
Next up is Cloud NAT.
This is our integrated network
address translation service.
Like our firewall, it's
built into the fabric
and provides
security and privacy
for outbound connections
with the ability
to use static or
auto-allocated IPs.
And like our firewall,
it's built into the network
fabric versus a single gateway.
So you can scale it up
to thousands of VMs.
And in terms of
recent innovations,
we have two great additions
in preview now at the show.
The first is NAT
rules, which allow
for tighter control over
which external IPs are
used for different
internal requesters.
For example, you
can ensure a service
making requests out over NAT
always uses the same public IP
address.
And then we introduced a
new capability in preview
called dynamic port allocation.
This allows for higher scale
by automatically optimizing NAT
port utilization in real time.
Previously, customers
had to manually configure
port allocations across VMs.
And they were generally
over-allocated.
Now the system does it for
you on its own automatically.
And we just recently announced
our new Cloud IDS product,
which provides for
managed network threat
detection with high
levels of security
efficacy and low noise.
It's quick and easy to deploy.
It's managed, scaled,
and operated by Google,
with high performance and
availability all built in.
It's super easy to set up.
With a few clicks,
you just select
what you want to monitor,
which types of monitoring
you want to enable, and then
the logging and telemetry
is all integrated into
all our own systems,
like Cloud Logging, Chronicle.
And all the alerts flow to SCC.
We can also send the alerts and
telemetry to third-party SIEM
and SOAR products as well.
And then we're super excited
to share that we partnered
with our friends at
Palo Alto Networks
to embed their
industry-leading threat
detection technologies
in the product.
So this ensures we have
industry-leading detection
capabilities, both
in terms of breadth
of coverage and efficacy.
And it's all backed
by their expert,
production-proven technologies
and world-class threat
intelligence teams,
but all nicely
integrated into Google Cloud,
sold and supported by us.
In fact, I wanted you to hear
from our GM of IaS, Sachin
Gupta, and Palo Alto
Networks's SVP, Anand Oswal,
more about the collaboration
that led to this product.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANAND OSWAL: The introduction
of Google Cloud IDS--
SACHIN GUPTA:
That's right, Anand.
It's been an
incredible partnership.
And we're now taking it
to a completely new level.
Over the last year,
our engineering teams
have worked together to build
a new joint product that
combines the industry-leading
capabilities of Palo Alto
Networks in advanced
network threat detection
with the simplicity and
scale of Google Cloud.
We're calling this product Cloud
IDS, a cloud-native service
delivered to all our customers.
With just a few
clicks, customers
can inspect traffic, get
application-level visibility,
and detect advanced threats.
They don't need to
worry about throughput.
worry about redirecting
network traffic to the service.
It's all done in
a cloud-native way
as part of the normal workflow.
They don't need to
worry about scale.
This is a service that's always
on, that is highly performant,
and that scales on demand.
This is Google Cloud
simplicity at its finest.
And it's something that
customers should consider
deploying in every single VPC.
Anand, why don't you talk
more about the strength
of the security capabilities
that Palo Alto Networks brings
as part of Cloud IDS?
ANAND OSWAL: Absolutely, Sachin.
The core of what we do
in the Cloud IDS product
is a network threat
detection engine.
This is a machine
learning-powered engine.
It looks at over 15 trillion
transactions every single day.
With all our network security
products and our endpoints,
we are constantly looking
at millions and millions
of samples of malware.
These are processed to ensure
that we protect our customers
from day-zero threats.
We are pushing over 4.3
million unique security
updates every single day.
And that's not enough.
In addition to our
automated analysis,
we have 200 of our
finest threat researchers
of our Unit 42 organization
that do in-depth research
and have the best understanding
of the entire threat landscape.
But Sachin, the point
you talked about,
combining simplicity
and showing that you're
having security-- we are
bringing these two together
with this joint product.
SACHIN GUPTA: If you'd like
to learn more about Cloud IDS,
go to cloud.google.com/ids.
PETER BLUM: We love
the collaboration
with Palo Alto
Networks, which has
led to a super easy to deploy
network threat detection
system, but with
production-proven high
efficacy, all powered
by Palo Alto Networks.
Well, thanks so much
for joining us today.
And thank you, Emil, for
co-presenting with me.
We were glad you
were able to join
us to learn more about
innovations in DDoS, firewalls,
and network threat detection.
You can visit us on the
web at cloud.google.com
/products/networking.
And then the Cloud
networking team
has a great set of
sessions during Next,
where you can learn more
about how we're simplifying
networking, delivering new
services, and all about what
we're doing on the edge.
Thanks again.